[Music]
so all day today we have been talking
about the current state of the world and
with the Rona are Katja with aronia and
our conversation you own Yakko bees our
conversations have led to us discussing
about like how would we protect
ourselves if things really hit the fan
and so this article here is really
interesting because it kind of taps into
that because these two serial burglars
they were caught breaking into a lot of
businesses and stuff and they thought
that they would get away with it because
they thought that the cops would be busy
handling like you know the Rona stuff
yeah yeah
Koby crisis stuff but they were busted
and the cops ended up saying like hey
see this don't do this [ __ ] people don't
be burglars because you will get caught
we're still [ __ ] doing our job and
[ __ ] you guys I've seen a more I've seen
a bigger police presence actually I like
all they get they they're wearing masks
you what do they look like influencers
or something you got beat up look at his
eyes oh [ __ ] I wish they had a law like
during pandemic if you like oral crises
and you try to take advantage of it then
police are allowed to beat the [ __ ] out
of you oh don't be so cool oh yeah so I
feel like that is where the rise of
crime is gonna happen is because cops or
people might be busy doing other things
and then when they're distracted that's
when the these lurkers come out there's
so many sirens throughout today true
more than usual HP's around here okay
have you guys been noticing a lot more
sirens though in your neighborhoods not
in ours ours is so quiet I've been
noticing way less cars people biking
around jogging saying hi a lot of
joggers dude I see a lot of people that
look like they never jog like jogging
like they'll be running like this and
[ __ ] I'm like dude they look so unfit
and I'm all like but good for you it's
making people and [ __ ] do things they
never do before that's true cuz I
actually started like sitting at the
piano and
I never [ __ ] do that that's dull yeah
I did it just one Tyco was getting
sleepy so really I'll put him in the car
we'll drive around and then while we're
driving alike let's be hall monitors so
we drove by like malls and would look in
the parking lot it's all I have to like
good like and there's all these
businesses just shut down I'm like yeah
I know there was this one point so it's
been like three weeks right about three
weeks that we were at home and somewhere
around like the middle wish I had to
move my car for a reason and so I ended
up moving my car but instead of just
moving it around the block I was like
like a few more blocks and so I kind of
went around like the whole neighborhood
cuz I'm like I miss driving I forgot
what this felt like and so I don't know
just that like small like cruise around
the neighborhood I'm like oh yeah oh I
wish I'll use this chill yeah [ __ ]
wish la like the traffic has been nice
yeah it's been non-existent mm-hmm less
clutter or less noise it's just like
calm it's really really calm right yeah
wailing smog dude the air is so nice to
breathe that was one of the conspiracy
theories that like climate climate
activism Ibiza
oh yeah climate activists started the
krona bar so they can clear the smog oh
my god we got really good at making
viruses don't give a [ __ ] about humans
we should stay at home water every other
month we do this like every year every
time addressing the pictures of India
it's crazy the difference the pictures
in India really yeah yeah cuz did you
know India is like super smoggy too and
then they have all these pictures where
is a completely blue sky it's dead
the Italian canals yeah in Venice you
can actually leave the fish that's crazy
rich we're dirtying up the world dude
humans your son that he was so stupid
now and I go to the grocery store you
all you see is these on the floor gloves
and [ __ ] someone has to clean this I see
people leaving gloves like in the car
yeah like they're done with it and then
they're just like and I'm like what's
wrong with you [ __ ] faces dude no that's
the problem then they're humans yeah if
it's not their problem there's knives
they don't care you know
littering is it's punishable by death
well that's the thing in America like
why it's getting so bad is because in
every other country they have respect
for the neighbors their people and they
just run a little different obviously
have more government control but like
here it's they only care about
themselves so they'll go out where they
want they'll buy everything out though
hoard stuff that they don't need that
much yeah but just because they're being
selfish I mean it's it's because it's an
independent culture right so when you
the culture is more about
self-sufficiency know that it's
different from an elective mindset yeah
we're like in Japan right like you put
on a face mask when you're sick so you
don't get other people sick
but then in America we don't do that
because if you're just sick you just you
go right that's true and if you see
someone where when you're like you're
weird and you talk [ __ ] to them well in
America you go I'm vegan so no one else
eats meat around me Oh comfort everyone
with Americans you go to other countries
and make them converts oh my god like
why don't these people still worse dude
when I was traveling I realized why
America gets so much [ __ ] hate like
watching Americans and I'm probably as
just as [ __ ] bad but the way that
they breathe they just don't [ __ ]
study countries before they go to a
country and they're just acting like a
fool at the restaurants asking for all
this [ __ ] and it's like god damn dude
why don't you just at least get to know
and a different culture instead of being
so [ __ ] entitled to like this is how
it should be like I can't and then you
expect them like they're rude but it's
like maybe they're not rude in their
culture but I've seen it like just watch
other couples like having a terrible
time or whatever I'm just like damn dude
[ __ ] you guys I mean so supposed to have
it good to have a good time here on
vacation but they're like a waiter stuff
he would just like to know that how can
you have such as why do you make it so
easy for yourself to have such a shitty
time on vacation like I'm like my stress
levels goes down by 30% or whatever
every time I'm out somewhere else
because I'm just like oh this is new I
don't have my regular work like stresses
I really do that you know what -
craziest American reaction to this Panda
- this Rona if you're the grocery stores
you can't find ketchup anywhere before
like it's been like anywhere I've done
to the Asian market the ketchup will
completely empty I've been finding
ellicott so weird I've been setting
features to all the editors I'm like
look I went to another grocery store
ketchup completely gone there's only one
bottle and it was expired you prepare
your soil responsible well I think si
knows expired it was brown does anyone
know that why the paper towels are like
gonzo yeah we can I get the toilet paper
right but paper towels like why bottled
water maybe because he went out to
Latino I got like our water supply is
[ __ ] up earthquake filtered water
that's Mike oh yeah but in California
you're pretty much good anyway checking
out of the tap like only together
technically you just taste nasty that's
true just I love the taste of tap water
what I hate the taste of water water
what we're tasting oily mineral water
royally there's no oil
I think it's cold you're good boil your
tongue is weird dude that could taste
the [ __ ] copper out of a la tap yeah
you could taste them any job is known
for being pretty good oh you haven't had
England tap also Austrian tap Hawaiian
tell that I
in England there like some of the best
it is dude it's [ __ ] Bob I've tried
England though this whole thing cuz like
coke try to get a husband with a coke
try to get know what is Dasani there
yeah not a whole conspiracy yeah like it
this so designs of like all our bottle
water because in America we're not used
to having good tap water so for them
they're like we all our water is great
and amazing from the tap so buy bottled
water spend more money on bag of water
the gates free yeah right
yeah good spring water in America we're
just like okay because this is bad than
what comes out of my house and if I
don't if I can't do this on die they
have such a supply of water just from
the sky all the time though you know
here with the get past you from a lake
that's like 300 miles away bring it over
here we're dry as [ __ ] homie yeah dry as
[ __ ]
the Berkey filters they work great yeah
man rookie
I was surprised although the Alps you
know Austrian into all those areas yet
though all those fat tap was I was
shocked cuz we're not used to just
grabbing a cup going to the [ __ ]
bathroom and drinking water out of the
tap I was like this is so [ __ ] whole
- it's like it's like iced water coming
out of here tap water from different
countries man how wasn't Tahoe oh really
water ooh just Canabalt in the water or
bottled should start a service where you
get tap water from around the world and
you've been try different ones Oh
Americans like brown yeah yeah Vegas
that water
oh dude Vegas tap water I swear smells
like pool water yeah have you ever taken
a shower in Vegas and then yeah like and
then you get out of the shower and you
feel like the water dried your [ __ ]
skin I don't feel like that is that I
thought that was the weather there like
I was to give the towels because the
towels are so like that - water's
thicker - like the water tastes like a
milkshake almost I mean I've got wall
but I can see
[Laughter]
it tastes like them like like a water
shake like it's like but like when I
brush my teeth I'm used to be another
boy and like water come out but just
feels like thicker for some reason it's
just so dried out from the day yeah I go
are given the water dehydrated that's
that's how I feel like do you know
there's that that thing that's thick
water is just pure water but it's for
people that can't swallow is good what's
little thick water yeah thick water why
does it help them solve it yes a thick
water drink you know what people were
doing is they were canning air from
different like parts of the world yeah
anything you could open it and smell it
and that's the greatest that's a huge
thing in Asia yeah huge market literally
is called thickened water it's for
people to help them swallow it says
sugar and calories free xanthine based
clear advantage so you feel fuller pure
hydration without added lemon chili he
didn't breathe it I don't know you know
what I've been thinking too okay so like
you know baked goods
I think tap is a huge ingredient to that
bake good cuz in New York their tap is
different too that's how they make their
bagels yeah and I don't know why New
York yeah and Europe their tap since
it's so [ __ ] good their baked [ __ ] is
good too and even ramen to guys where
they say the ramen here can never taste
like Japan cuz the Japan tap is Bob too
man way different made in Jalisco cannot
be made here because of the water
yeah and hitting meas food here's better
because the water over there sucks
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]